hi guys only see it here with another
GameSpot news update Microsoft's
earnings are up as a whole eighteen
percent to twenty three point four
billion dollars so looks like
everything's coming up Microsoft well
kinda as part of their quarterly
earnings report the green giant
announced that they've sold in 1.1
million xbox one and xbox 360 consoles
between April first and June thirtieth
but let's examine the exec you speak
sold in refers to the number of consoles
shipped to retailers as opposed to the
number of consoles actually sold to
consumers a figure we haven't been
updated on since microsoft announced
that three million xbox one consoles
have been bought by gamers as of
december 31st and while 1.1 million
consoles sounds like a lot it's a steep
drop compared to the prior three months
when microsoft shipped two million
consoles 1.2 million of which were Xbox
one's the company explained they were
going to slow shipments in order to
allow retailers to actually sell the
consoles they already have on store
shelves which is quite a few apparently
and it turns out that when it comes to
console sales things might be better
without connect microsoft announced last
week that xbox one sales had more than
doubled in june compared with May
following the release of the four
hundred dollar connects free model that
brings the system's price down to that
of the PlayStation 4 which as of april
six had sold seven million units
worldwide so microsoft little bit of
catching up to do the device is in
consumer hardware group which will now
be known as the computing and gaming
hardware group or car for short will
continue to include both xbox and
surface the car posted revenue of 1.44
billion dollars for q4 of last year an
almost twenty-five percent year-on-year
increase thanks in part to a big boost
from the Xbox platform this report comes
after news of mass layoffs at the
company while the main Xbox platform
will be unaffected Xbox entertainment
studios is being shut down as Microsoft
are choosing to invest their efforts
into console gaming and xbox live while
keeping an eye on the board of pc and
mobile markets which are quite thick
who knew so how's gaming working out on
your surface is car just Klingon the
Microsoft is this all just one big giant
conspiracy well for all the latest
gaming conspiracies stay tuned hits
against bar